So element ununpentium, that’s the element
115, is in the same group of
the periodic table as nitrogen, phosphorus,
antimony, and arsenic, and
so we can, even without knowing or seeing
a real sample, we can tell
quite a lot about what the chemistry might
be like. This is, after all, what
Mendeleev’s triumph with the periodic table
was, that he looked at where
there were holes in the periodic table where
he reckoned there should be
elements and he predicted their properties
so that we can tell that this
element, Uup, is going to be in some ways
like the elements in the Group
15. Group 15 here, if you can look, is the
one that is nitrogen,
phosphorous, arsenic, antimony and bismuth,
and it will be down here. Until
recently I used to lecture on Group 15 and
I mentioned when this Uup
had been discovered I set a little exam question
and asked the students
which group it would be in, thinking that
they would have to count it, and
not realising that the exam paper had a periodic
table with it marked in
the right place, so they got some marks for
free.